[Musik]
hallo liebe lobby freunde
sorry kurze sms schreiben angie kummer
hör auf zu werbern kummer draußen stehen
vertreter der waffenlobby senden sie ist
die wirkliche politik wird nicht vorne
am rednerpult gemacht schwing die hufe
also das ging früher auch mal flotter
das ist quasi mein büro
ich kann hier vom balkon auf meine
angestellten runter gucken ja im
bundestag haben 865 lobbyisten einen
hausausweis das heißt bei 7 109
parlamentarier sind das mehr lobbyisten
als abgeordnete da darf man politik
nicht politiker darüber lassen
besonders beim thema waffen in
deutschland sind waffen ja total
überreguliert 1000 vorschriften streng
genommen
da durfte ich noch nicht mal diese
handgranate dabei haben und deswegen
brauchen wir eine starke waffenlobby wir
müssen die politiker immer und immer
wieder davon überzeugen wie wichtig es
ist waffen ins ausland zu exportieren
allein schon wegen der sicherheit 2014
wollte sigmar gabriel als
wirtschaftsminister deutsche
waffenexporte einschränken
ob hier war es eingeschränkt wird
entscheiden die hersteller nicht
irgendwelche minister von tower nicht
mal eine freundin hab ich im puff gehen
darf danke sehr aufmerksam
wir brauchen waffenexporte wohin soll
denn bitte heckler & koch rheinmetall
und krauss maffei denn sonst ihre waffen
verkaufen
sauerland dann doch lieber saudi arabien
die kämpfen damit dem jemen e-werk
narren haben will der kriegt sie auch
waffen waffen worten hier wir brauchen
alles was coop um 4,9 millionen drauf
ich glaube ich muss mit kommen so hier
wer heute dich zu schlägt er wird schuss
nicht
die große koalition hat den vergangenen
vier jahren mehr rüstungsexporte
genehmigt als union und fdp davor mit
guter lobby-arbeit ist es eigentlich
egal wer regiert und keiner kann
kontrollieren wo die knarren am ende hin
gehen reisetipp besucht deutsche waffen
in schlimmsten krisengebieten in jemand
im sudan libyen syrien georgien im
mexikanischen drogenkrieg wie cool ist
das denn längst das teil alter wir
scheißen auf die regeln mai mitteilt zum
beispiel baut bomben in einer
tochterfirma auf sardinien ja von
deutschland aus dürfen die bomben
nämlich nicht nach saudi arabien
verkauft werden
jetzt sagt drei metall deutschland ja
warum dort ist eine italienische firma
haben wir nichts mit zu tun
die italiener sagen ist die deutsche
firma da haben wir nichts mehr zu tun
stransky patiniert die rheinmetall aktie
ist im letzten jahr um 70 prozent
gestiegen win win win win win situation
warte mal da fällt man mit sein
[Musik]
hier wurde aber ich habe noch ein ja der
ist so lustig wie ein loch im kopf
treffen sich zwei deutsche
panzerhaubitzen den himmel sagt die eine
was machst du denn hier ist doch
krisengebiet lass mal lieber nach
nordsyrien gehen sagt die andere aber
dass auch kriegsgebiet ja das recht aber
den ich glaube wir hier ein sturmgewehr
eine mütze aber die waffenlobby gibt der
gesellschaft auch viel zurück der
frühere verteidigungsminister franz
josef jung sitzt heute im aufsichtsrat
von rheinmetall und der frühere
fdp-generalsekretär dirk niebel ist
cheflobbyist des konzerns hey ihr
dachtet wahrscheinlich der niebel wäre
damals entwicklungsminister gewesen
er hat sich nur schon mal die länder
angeguckt in dir später waffen liefern
wollte sushi jetzt wo ich ab ins büro
die arbeit ruft für mehr
verteidigungsausgaben sonst verpasse ich
dich bei donald trump
[Musik]